ios 8 isn't as much of a break with the
past like ios 7 was that operating
system was famous for introducing an
entire new design the changes in ios 8
are more functional less aesthetic here
are five of the most important ones
in the past when you got a notification
that somebody had either emailed or
texted you you had to read the alert
then open the app then find the message
and then reply to it in ios 8 you can
respond to a notification directly
within the notification itself it works
really well and it allows you to get
back to people very quickly without
interrupting whatever else you were
doing
like other os's such as android and even
blackberry apple's os now has a keyboard
that predicts words as you type them
apple says the system can learn your
writing style and make suggestions based
on it as of now it's good in theory but
i wish the suggestions would come up a
little faster also when you have a bar
of suggested words above the keyboard
you limit the amount of visible screen
that you can type on if you don't like
it you can always turn it off
you can now record your voice and send
it to someone as a
text this may seem silly because you
might ask yourself but isn't that what
the phone was for actually it makes a
lot of sense
i'll be there in five minutes
i'll be there in five minutes for the
kind of phone calls that i generally
make this is going to replace a lot of
them
apple's mail app has some new swiping
features which are actually pretty nice
from the inbox you can perform several
mail functions without having to open an
individual message but more importantly
apple finally seems to have gotten
search right on its mail app after using
gmail's app for years because apple mail
search was so lousy the combination of
the new features and an improved search
function may have me coming back
if your device is plugged in you can now
activate siri with your voice just say
hey siri
apple's competitors had this feature for
a while so it's not surprising that the
company would include it one place that
this feature is very useful the car
if some of these features sound familiar
it's because they are we've seen them on
competing devices in the past but
apple's never shy from taking an
existing technology refining it and then
including it in its own devices as for
the question should i upgrade just
remember the downloader's rule the first
version of any software is likely to
have some bugs in it if you can hold out
apple always pushes out an update in the
coming weeks that irons out all the
kinks
you